speaking of family dwayne you also just
recently bought your mom a house
i did that like makes me want to cry
no no no wait i got a concept
it's about a billion dollars later he
finally blows my miles all right should
we clap for that
i think the whole room right now is
taking the same thing
you got a crooked nose when your ears is
[ __ ] up your top lip is stupid your
hairline is [ __ ] up and one of my ears
is dumb
and your skin complexion makes my balls
itch
what was the the motivation uh my little
girl she came in jazzy was like daddy
i didn't want to draw on your face and
she woke me up and i was like okay
give me one big uni brother i'm saying
she gave me a unibrow on purpose that's
something just gave me that mustache the
stash on the ends i don't know i'm kind
of into the that clearly shows yeah
right clearly shows that your kid
doesn't like you
is there a kevin picture no there's not
one we specifically came to troll you
and have kevin support the truth wow
okay my kids what's it called love me
what's that
you got a crooked nose one of your ears
is [ __ ] up your hairline's [ __ ] up
your lip is crooked
your eye went down
and your balls
it's darker than mine
yeah
wow
see that smoke there it is what are you
doing i'm pulling this out
words i never say
i
i
had worked with vanessa before multiple
times on saturday night live she's
outfits were very talented kevin we're a
big fan of him and all his beverly hills
cop movies i've never done it
i've never done beverly hills that
wasn't oh it's eddie murphy that's right
that's right yeah
and what have you got yeah
that is the greatest gift of all time
show the world yeah sure i'll show them
i got a nice piece of toilet paper
santa don't laugh at that great and we
had a hallway bumped in uh i forgot the
awards show okay what award was
backstage we saw each other just before
we met i do remember that
he was like hey rock and i was like um
complete kevin's twitter bio my name is
kevin hart and i am a piece of [ __ ] come
on
stop it that's not a piece
of
in my bio and your bio i'm gonna say i'm
a piece of [ __ ] buy it would you not say
that in my bio that's the kind of
comedian you are self-deprecating like
that that's what makes you brilliant
i'm passing the phone to someone who
gets so scared of junkets at any kind of
animals especially butterflies i'm
passing phones somebody that has no hair
but they have all forehead i'm passing
the phone to someone who uh will be
starring in his own superhero movie
called honky pete
i'm passing the phone to somebody that
doesn't watch the back of their knees
don't encourage that guys i'm passing
the phone to someone who lost his
virginity when he was
22 years old
i'm passing the phone to somebody that
flips their underwear inside out because
they're too lazy to go watch them
correctly wow
i'm passing the phone back to someone
who wears a thong backwards
i'm passing the phone to somebody that
doesn't have a big toe
i'm passing the phone to someone who's
still trying to find out who his real
father is
i'm passing the phone to somebody that's
been lying about his hawaiian heritage
for his whole career
get the [ __ ] out of the way oh
i don't walk oh i'm so big oh
you got me i'm the rock i'm the biggest
movie
on jumanji
[Laughter]
i would like to know what you would do
if you could spend 24 hours in in kevin
hart's body
how would you spend your day kill myself
that's what i do wait a second no no no
i wouldn't do that it's a great day it
is a great you had an opportunity for a
terrific day all right 24 hours in the
rock's body bro all right 15 he'd be
playing himself
[Laughter]
and i'mma go redo some of the movies i
want to do scorpion you want to redo it
i'm a redo scorpion no i just wanna i
just want to be a part of that i've yet
to have that and i'm gonna go to like
fast i'm gonna go to fast 26.
fast and fear is 26. do you guys have
any party tricks or anything oh we have
many i can't go with that
well first can you wait a second
wait what's mine
that's your time dj can ties balls
[Laughter]
and without using my hands
i just kind of
i shake my hips
[Music]
beautiful very good
we talked about this week he made some
news this week by saying that he has a
habit of peeing in a water bottle while
he's working out okay were you aware of
this have you seen this happen in your
in your works out with mr mr dwayne
johnson it's not news to me he smelled
like urine for years uh
can you talk to him because he makes no
it makes no sense to me the workers
at a certain point you know when a
person has a problem he's dealing with
something else um you know so this is
compensating yeah there were times on
set where i was like should we say
something and everybody was like he's
big and i was like yeah let's just let
it happen let's just let it happen this
morning your pal kevin hart
got you know it's one thing to get a
star on hollywood boulevard it is
another level all together to get your
hands and feet yes impressed in cement
yes and that is a big deal it's
legendary yes yes and i had the honor of
speaking on his behalf and he did
i did yes and it was an amazing ceremony
how much thought did you put into it did
you write did you really think about
what you were going to say
i mean it's kevin hart i didn't give it
[Laughter]
what uh what what what type of uh what
type of person
were you in school ladies man
nerd which one class clown house glass
cloud that's class count back in high
school the class clown because i was the
one i was just making everybody laugh i
was the one who i would throw my voice
i would throw my voice like hey he did
the thing and then
i'm kevin hart right right in high
school okay um yeah hey hey hey
hey everybody hey
hey girl
hey girl
hey no
she ain't hear me
come on
come on
hey miss johnson yeah
i'm gonna do good on that test
best thing about being tall
is um you're closer to god
and jesus in the heavens
because
it's a blessing
yeah to be that high yeah yeah so what's
yours best thing about being small good
clothes my my piece of advice for
anybody that's short is that it's okay
uh there's nothing that comes with being
tall outside of a conversation there's
just nothing that comes from
nothing no there's nothing that comes no
advantage at all tall people are stupid
we rock little guys
[Music]
um
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
my eardrum oh that's just trying to keep
up with the younger generation right
there we're again uh go see our movie
29th it comes out super pets all right
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] [ __ ] eardrums